imagine our friend living in a
two-dimensional World here they are
standing between two galaxies which are
both radiating light and the
gravitational force in this world light
is confined to two Dimensions but the
gravitational pull from the galaxies
might spread out in all directions like
an expanding sphere if they're
two-dimensional Universe were bent or
Twisted in an unusual way like this our
friend wouldn't be able to see the light
from the galaxies until it traveled all
this distance and back to them the
gravity on the other hand could Traverse
higher Dimensions or in this case across
the boundary of the folded up Universe
this might explain the mystery of dark
matter if our own Universe was folded up
in a similar manner If gravity could
extend into higher dimensions then we
could potentially feel the gravitational
effects of a distant Galaxy maybe
billions of years before we are actually
able to see it